werben mit festen präpositionen teil 2 2
b1 denken an und akkusativ an wen denkst
du an wen denkst du ich denke an meinen
hund ich denke an meinen hund denkst du
an deinen hund denkst du an deinen hund
ja ich denke an ihn ja ich denke an ihn
sich erinnern an und akkusativ erinnerst
du dich an erich wir haben ihn an der
party getroffen
erinnerst du dich an erich wir haben ihn
an der party getroffen
ja jetzt erinnere ich mich an ihn ja
jetzt erinnere ich mich an ihn sich
gewöhnen an und akkusativ hast du dich
schon an das scharfe essen gewöhnt hast
du dich schon an das scharfe essen
gewöhnt nein ich habe mich noch nicht
daran gewöhnt
nein ich habe mich noch nicht daran
gewöhnt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich mich daran gewöhnt jetzt
habe ich mich daran gewöhnt glauben an
und akkusativ woran glaubst du woran
glaubst du ich glaube an buddha ich
glaube an buddha teilnehmen an und da
tief
nimmst du auch an der sitzung teil
ja ich nehme auch daran teil
zweifeln an und da tief woran zweifelst
du woran zweifelst du ich zweifle an der
banknote
ich zweifle an der banknote sich freuen
auf und akkusativ worauf freust du dich
worauf freust du dich ich freue mich auf
die party am samstag
ich freue mich auf die party am samstag
warten auf und akkusativ worauf wartest
du
worauf wartest du
ich warte auf den bus ich warte auf den
bus
sich konzentrieren auf und akkusativ
worauf konzentrierst du dich worauf
konzentrierst du dich ich konzentriere
mich auf meine arbeit ich konzentriere
mich auf meine arbeit aufpassen auf und
akkusativ auf wen oder was passt du auf
wen oder was passt du auf ich passe auf
das kind und den verkehr auf ich passe
auf das kind und den verkehr auf
antworten auf und akkusativ worauf
antwortest du worauf antwortest du ich
antworte auf seine frage ich antworte
auf seine frage
hoffen auf und akkusativ worauf hoffst
du worauf hoffst du ich hoffe auf
frieden
ich hoffe auf frieden sich verlassen auf
und akkusativ auf wen verlässt du dich
auf wen verlässt du dich ich verlasse
mich auf meine freunde ich verlasse mich
auf meine freunde verzichten auf und
akkusativ
worauf verzichtet du worauf verzichtet
du ich verzichte auf fleisch ich
verzichte auf fleisch lust haben auf und
akkusativ worauf hast du lust worauf
hast du lust
ich habe lust auf eine cola
ich habe lust auf eine cola sich
interessieren für und akkusativ wofür
interessierst du dich wofür
interessierst du dich ich interessiere
mich für bücher ich interessiere mich
für bücher sorgen für und akkusativ für
wen sorgst du für wen sorgst du ich
sorge für meine mutter
ich sorge für meine mutter
geld ausgeben für und akkusativ wofür
gibst du geld aus wofür gibst du geld
aus ich gebe geld für technik aus
ich gebe geld für technik aus sich
entscheiden für und akkusativ wofür
entscheidest du dich wofür entscheidest
du dich ich entscheide mich für das
weiße t-shirt ich entscheide mich für
das weiße t-shirt sich bedanken bei und
dativ person für und akkusativ sache bei
wem bedankt du dich wofür bei wem
bedankt du dich wofür ich bedanke mich
bei ihr für das geschenk
ich bedanke mich bei ihr für das
geschenk sich entschuldigen bei und
dativ person für und akkusativ sache bei
wem entschuldigt du dich wofür bei wem
entschuldigt du dich wofür ich
entschuldige mich bei ihm für den fehler
ich entschuldige mich bei ihm für den
fehler sich beschweren bei und dativ
person über und akkusativ sache bei wem
beschwert du dich vorüber bei wem
beschwert du dich worüber ich beschwere
mich bei dem kellner über den service
ich beschwere mich bei dem kellner über
den service klagen bei und dativ person
über und akkusativ thema bei wem klacks
worüber bei wem klar worüber ich klage
bei ihr über mein leben ich klage bei
ihr über mein leben
sich bewerben bei und dativ firma um und
akkusativ stelle bei wem bewirbst du
dich vor um bei wem bewirbst du dich
warum ich bewerbe mich bei der firma um
die stelle als mechaniker ich bewerbe
mich bei der firma um die stelle als
mechaniker
träumen von und da tief
wovon träumst du wovon träumst du ich
träume von meinem urlaub ich träume von
meinem urlaub ich träume von meinem
urlaub sprechen von und da tief von wem
sprichst du von wem sprichst du ich
spreche von ihr
ich spreche von ihr
angst haben vor und dativ angst haben
vor und dativ wovor hast du angst wovor
hast du angst ich habe angst vor der
maus ich habe angst vor dem aus warnen
vor und dativ wovor wanst du wovor warst
du ich warne vor der strafe
ich warne vor der strafe
gemacht sein aus und dativ material
woraus ist der tisch gemacht
der tisch ist aus holz gemacht der tisch
ist aus holz gemacht
folge uns halo deutsch schule deutsch
lernen mit spaß